- So wait, you went to Argentina recently,
where your wife's from.
- Yeah.
- So do you love going there?
Like what do y'all do there?
- Oh, I love Argentina, yeah.
It's a great country.
- Yeah.
- Great, really great people.
- It's beautiful.
- Who just said, "Woohoo"?
- Woo!
(audience laughs)
- Oh!
- See, there you go.
Shout out.
- [Michael] You're from Argentina?
- Are you serious?
- Aww, beautiful.
- Hola.
Mucho gusto, mi amor!
- What are the chances?
(audience laughs)
- That's very good.
- Great country.
- [Kelly] Some crazy happenstance.
It's like, what--
- Yeah, no.
It's a big country.
- Yeah.
- My wife will say, "Argentina,
we have the best women,"
"the best meat, the best football."
"We have the Pope."
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- "We have, we have."
- We have the Pope.
So, no. (stammers)
When I go there, it's usually
'cause my wife makes movies.
She's a big movie star.
- Oh, yeah.
- So I'm the set bitch.
I go.
(audience laughs)
That's who I am.
- So I'm that guy.
- I'm that guy, I show up.
- Do you like, miss your mom?
Show up with the kids?
- I bring this stuff.
I get the trailer already.
Maybe a little massage,
and take care of the kids.
- Oh my gosh.
- And, you know.
Set bitch, get me some water!
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
Set bitch.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh my God.
Y'all need your own show.